el herpes genital es un tipo de
enfermedad o infección de transmisión
sexual frecuente es más frecuente en las
mujeres que en los hombres
la infección suele afectar a los
genitales que son los órganos
reproductores dentro
y fuera del cuerpo
también puede afectar a los glúteos la
zona anal
o la boca
el herpes genital suele estar causado
por el virus del herpes simple tipo 2 o
bhs-2 Aunque el virus del herpes simple
tipo 1 o vhs 1 puede causar también el
pez genital es más frecuente que
provoque una infección en los labios la
boca o las encías provoca ampollas
dolorosas a menudo conocidas como herpes
labial a esto se lo llama herpes oral
ocasionalmente el vhs-2 también puede
causar herpes oral se puede contraer el
virus del herpes de una persona
infectada a través del contacto personal
y directo durante el sexo genital u oral
el virus puede entrar en el cuerpo a
través de una lesión en la piel o a
través del tejido que recubre muchas de
las cavidades corporales como el tejido
que recubre la boca y los genitales
una vez dentro de la piel el virus puede
multiplicarse en las células
esto daña las células e inflama la piel
lo que provoca llagas dolorosas mientras
el organismo trata de controlar la
infección cuando la piel empieza a
curarse algunos virus entran en las
ramificaciones de las células nerviosas
llamadas axones
el virus se propaga a través de los
axones hasta una zona cercana a la
médula espinal donde se vuelve latente o
inactivo esto se conoce como la etapa
latente del herpes más adelante ciertos
factores desencadenantes como el estrés
las enfermedades la exposición a la luz
solar y la menstruación pueden hacer que
el virus se active de nuevo
Cuando esto ocurre el virus puede volver
por los axones hasta la piel
y provocar otra Ronda de llagas
el principal riesgo de contraer el
herpes genital es tener sexo oral anal o
vaginal con una persona infectada existe
un mayor riesgo de que un hombre
infectado se lo transmita a una mujer no
infectada durante las relaciones
sexuales vaginales que una mujer
infectada se lo transmita un hombre no
infectado esto puede ocurrir porque el
tejido de la vagina de la mujer es más
propenso a sufrir pequeños desgarros lo
que permite que el virus ingrese en el
organismo el riesgo de infección también
aumenta a medida que aumenta la cantidad
de parejas sexuales
si tiene el virus de la
inmunodeficiencia humana o VIH tiene un
mayor riesgo de contraer herpes genital
muchas personas nunca tienen síntomas y
no hay síntomas durante las etapas
latentes
pero los síntomas de una infección
activa en las mujeres incluyen llagas o
ampollas dolorosas en la zona genital
los sitios más comunes de infección son
los genitales en el exterior del cuerpo
también conocidos Como la vulva la
vagina el cuello del útero
el ano los muslos
y los glúteos
en los hombres los lugares habituales de
las llagas o ampollas son el pene el
escroto
el ano los muslos y los glúteos
tanto en los hombres como en las mujeres
las llagas también pueden aparecer en
los labios la lengua
las encías
los ojos
y los dedos
otros síntomas son dificultad o dolor al
orinar malestar general o síntomas
parecidos a los de la gripe y ganglios
linfáticos inflamados en la ingle en las
personas que tienen el sistema
inmunitario debilitado como las que
tienen el VIH las llagas genitales
pueden ser graves Y duraderas si su
sistema inmunitario está débil el virus
del herpes también puede extenderse a
otras partes del cuerpo Como por ejemplo
el cerebro y la médula espinal los ojos
el esófago los pulmones y el hígado
y durante el parto vaginal las mujeres
también pueden transmitir el virus del
herpes a su bebé recién nacido si se
infectan o tienen un brote secundario
cerca de la fecha del parto
no hay cura para el herpes genital una
vez infectado su cuerpo siempre
albergará el virus las personas que no
son sexualmente activas y que rara vez O
nunca tienen síntomas pueden no
necesitar ningún tratamiento pero el
médico puede recetar un medicamento
antiviral para prevenir o reducir los
síntomas como el Aciclovir o Elba la
ciclovir si solo tiene unos pocos brotes
al año es posible que solo necesite
medicación antiviral Durante cada brote
esto se llama tratamiento episódico si
tiene muchos brotes al año o si es
sexualmente activo puede tomar
medicamentos antivirales a diario esto
se llama tratamiento inhibidor de esta
manera se puede prevenir los brotes
reducir la cantidad de brotes reducir la
duración de los brotes y reducir el
riesgo de transmitir el herpes genital a
una pareja sexual
si tiene herpes genital tomar
medicamentos antivirales y utilizar
preservativos de látex durante las
relaciones sexuales puede ayudar a
prevenir el contagio a otras personas
para saber más sobre el herpes cenital
habla con su proveedor de atención
médica